he's fine he's got 150 cause yeah friend
of mine he's been very nice I'm allowed
to make shop it is stupid such an insult
now go get to my chick all the time yeah
you know I mean that's what was breaking
up okay it's called we gotta take what
we're just got a quick she was calling
me when she saw you on the show she's
going I thought you were coming on not
Carson Daly it's a dumb this is why I
keep breaking up with this girl because
isn't a show allowed to have more than
one person on it yes it should like
driving up you're on the cell phone
there's no way to win okay well we're
gonna take a quick commercial break
we'll be back now yeah and then we'll be
back Andrew Dice Clay is here where am I
looking every time I come up it's in a
setup
no but I'm just saying what what is this
girl that's waving what is that I just
didn't I know that crazy you know we're
just speaking about these young ladies
now yeah what are you guys what are you
guys doing together hearing us oh this
is that thing you started yeah the
invention I didn't invent it exactly my
respect mister I'm sorry just talking to
yourself
Justine yes where are you guys we're not
Angeles high brokers are you underage
I'm underage
I'm 23
no cuz I got okay now you're a little
too old
what do you a dancer Maya dancer yeah no
what do you do a new dancer
again two very famous the video prolific
young people on the internet both of
them do a lot of video making and Brooke
be nice you're grounded
they do a lot yes I do as do anybody
watching online they definitely no
broker's work and and I just Dean's to
that into computers I mean this could
never happen on my talk show I mean I
dig this I you know the delay it kills
me a little bit I gotta be honest but to
be talking like we were about you know
the Internet and then there's broker's
and there's Justina then they just Skype
you back and then thanks watching your
front door just making hamburgers I mean
everything that's going on the last 12
minutes
online and on broadcast he's blowing my
mind is it really yes it's rising me to
want to drink profusely this is
something he could make money from I'm
telling you this thing program Skype
program you know what I love about doing
the show Carson though is I've gotten to
get to know a lot of people her dice
yourself I remember the first time you
came up here we didn't know each other
now we're getting brunch on Sundays do
you know you know how long you gonna be
hanging for or whatever no I don't mean
today I mean you wouldn't tell days but
we should do that you know take a couple
of girls do another brunch thing Sunday
like a date yeah you know what I mean
instead of just us yeah you know cuz she
go with him while he tells you about I
got new cameras
you know would you film something in the
street I go it's pouring rain now what
am i filming field you know I make sure
we do I'm singing in the rain like
George Kelly did in the forties whatever
whatever his name was and we take Brooke
out we do something with them yeah maybe
the other one what's your name honey
what song did the other girl there what
does she get broken that's broken just
like ya sister whatever just let them go
poor girl show that with caution
you can ask you